First, let's pop the question, what is photogrammetry?
A quick Google search may give answers such as the science of making reliable measurements
from photographs and especially aerial photographs.
But for us 3D artists, it refers to the process of turning 2D images into 3D models,
an easy way to create a digital twin of a physical model.
This also allows you to automatically extract texture maps, which is an added bonus.
Photogrammetry is not the only technology available to create digital twins,
although it is arguably the most popular.
Other techs include LiDAR, also known as laser scanning,
and a newer technology known as NERF, which stands for neural radiance fields.
In this class, though, we'll just be focusing on photogrammetry.
To turn pictures into 3D models, you first need a set of pictures, of course.
How you take those pictures can have a definite impact on the generated 3D model.
The kind of camera you use can also impact the result.
Even though you can theoretically use any camera,
you get the best results with professional DSLR gear.
Try not to use any camera that is less than 16 megapixels in resolution.
The higher you go, the better.
There is more than just resolution that makes a good camera, though.
That's why you get the highest quality with DSLR cameras.
Point-and-shoot cameras come next,
and smartphone cameras are at the lower end of the spectrum,
although some work rather well.
If you decide to use drones for external shots,
keep in mind that you need a high-quality drone to get any acceptable results.
Many generic drones under $100 boast 4K cameras,
but none of them really works well.
If you're in the market for a drone,
go with an established brand like DJI or similar.
If your camera permits it,
shoot in manual mode to keep consistency across your pictures.
It's important to keep the subject in focus
by ensuring an adequate depth of field.
If you vary the aperture, or f-stop, on your camera,
this will allow you to control the amount of light to use Photoshop,
but a small f-stop value that allows for more light also reduces the depth of field,
potentially making parts of the subject defocused.
The same holds true when varying the focal length.
Given the same f-stop value,
a wide-angle lens will give you a larger depth of field than a telephoto lens.
Avoid changing zoom values on your cameras.
This affects the focal length.
Feel free to move the camera further away or closer to the subject, though.
That would be fine and even recommended.
If possible, use low ISO settings to minimize grain,
and shoot in RAW format if your camera allows it.
Finally, avoid using an automatic white balance
to avoid getting pictures with different color temperatures.
With these basic concepts covered, let's discuss setting the stage.
You can, of course, take pictures indoors or outdoors.
Indoor settings are easier as you can better control the environment.
However, it is usually restricted to small objects.
After all, you'd have a hard time bringing in a boulder or a fire hydrant indoors to photograph.
The idea is to take pictures from all around the subject, in circles or in arcs.
For that, you either physically move around the object,
or you use a turntable as you take pictures from different angles and distances.
It's important to move the camera as you take pictures.
Avoid using techniques that you would use for 3D panoramas.
For those, the camera would remain in the same spot as you rotated around.
This does not work for photogrammetry.
Take as many pictures as your patience allows.
The more pictures you take, the better the solution.
For exterior scenes, use a drone for large-scale models,
such as buildings and landmarks.
Speaking of exterior shots, try to do your photoshoot on an overcast day.
This reduces the harsh shadows that take place under direct sunlight.
You wouldn't want those shadows to be baked into the textures.
For interior shots, you can eliminate or at least drastically reduce shadows using soft-diffuse lighting.
There are such solutions for every budget,
from commercial photography soft-light box rigs to dollar store ring-led lights.
Ultimately, and for best practices, you may decide to equalize the pictures you've taken for consistency.
There are various applications that allow you to do that.
Some are commercial, while others are open-source.
I've listed a few on this slide for your convenience.
In the next video, we'll discuss some of the limitations that you will undoubtedly face when dealing with photogrammetry.